imitation can be the sincerest form of
flattery but when done right it can be
the best most effective form of satire
in honor of those who definitely
deconstruct the personalities of a
favorite public figures only to magnify
their flaws or eccentric cities by an
impression for amusement here are the 10
spot on impressions done by comedians
Frank Caliendo as Jon Gruden we're not
gonna be using technology man we're not
gonna be using GPS or video tape or word
processors man we're gonna go back to
tackling teach these K these kids how to
brush their teeth you know go to the
circle man floss for mercy you ever seen
those infomercials in your kid man tell
you what that's a good stuff right there
look like I'm trying to lay an egg rich
little as Johnny Carson and then one day
I was out of the San Diego Zoo and I was
looking at the ostriches and I suddenly
realized that's how to do Johnny Carson
think of an ostrich
[Applause]
why Wyatt please a home run and a triple
a first baseman's glove a catcher's
glove and Dolly Parton
[Applause]
my two big hips too big match Andy
Kaufman as Elvis Presley
[Music]
Eddie Murphy as Tracy Morgan I went over
there he made me prank more pop Franco
because she maybe them Frank J Moore as
Nam McDonald oh my god
dildos everywhere oh my god yeah I just
show hoarders and when you never see on
TV is apparently Matt Paxton told me
yeah yeah what a check hoarders love
dildos that's pretty where you know you
got all these newspapers and holiday
decorations are all about the house
there you know and I don't know we do
where you go in that box there buddy
yeah my dildos hey I'm not hoarding
dildos I can't stop [ __ ] myself with
manufactured penises there Anna I know
I'm a hoarder and have a terrible
terrible problem unable to let things go
but that's called a spade a spade here
buddy not throw out mommy's dildos Kevin
Spacey as Al Pacino Kevin how are you
nice to see oh shut up Dave
I worked on something just for this
moment okay I had to write it down
[Laughter]
okay
[Music]
here
heritage
truly awesome
Oh hug you but I get a cappuccino Jay
Pharoah as Eddie Murphy why why did it
take so long that's my question I should
have been happy and asked you see me
Jim Carrey as Andy Kaufman take my wife
please take her I I love my wife but she
don't know how to cook her cooking is so
bad it is terrible rich little Jimmy
Stewart now now the way I understand
that dr. Kane said that Miss Marple said
that the knife that was found on the
back of surrett tional
what's the same knife that was used in
the kitchen by the maid Winnie Annie
that originally belonged to the gardener
Ben Harper used it to spray putty off
the silver window somebody's lying Frank
Caliendo as John Madden you're in the
Hall of Fame and you're went to a new
network and everything how's all that
going yeah I made a new network I mean
you wouldn't know about switching
Network stay but I mean this is what I
was thinking that you know you go to a
different place and you do different
things and still work without Michaels
of course the greatest announcer in the
world if you don't count like 30 or 40
other guys I mean it's great
working there and great doing what we're
doing there and doing the things we do
it as long as we keep doing them I mean
it's familiar it's like the hokey-pokey
put your right foot idiot take your
right foot out you put your right foot
it is shake it all about you do the
Hokey Pokey and turn yourself around
their comment down below what you want
to see next
thanks and peace out
[Music]
[Music]